hi there I like I'm in the habit of
saying that I would like if butterflies
could talk but I've been recently
reconsidering that because we already
have a pretty loud world can you imagine
if butterflies were yakking out there
all over the place but I would like to
ask butterflies one question which is
what is the meaning of some of the
stories that we humans tell about them
because remarkably all over the world
cultures have really similar stories
similar mythologies about butterflies
having to do with the human soul some
cultures tell us butterflies are
carrying the souls of children who have
died wrongly or too soon and other
cultures tell us that butterflies are
carrying the souls of our ancestors
among us this butterfly is called Kalina
Inachus on one side it looks like a
beautiful butterfly and on the other
side it looks like a leaf and it folds
up like a leaf to elude predators so now
you see it now you don't something
hidden something revealed maybe we got
our ideas about the human soul from this
butterfly so it's possible that
butterflies have some sort of outside
out size role in our afterlife but in
this life in this world butterflies are
in really serious trouble this is a moth
moths and butterflies are related moths
generally fly at night this is called
predicta because Darwin predicted that
it must exist so today more than 60
species of butterflies are endangered
around the world but even more than that
insects are declining declining
declining in the last 50 years we've
lost nearly 50% of the total number of
bodies of insects now this is a disaster
it could it could impact us in a more
serious way more quickly than climate
change because butterflies don't do that
much in the ecosystem that we depend on
but they do things for other creatures
that we do depend on and that's the same
story with all insect life insect life
is at the very foul
datian of our life-support systems we
can't lose these these insects
biodiversity all over the globe is in a
vast decline habitat loss pesticides
herbicides and impacts of climate change
habitat loss is very serious and that's
where we really have to get developing
better more mindfully it's the worst of
times we are kind of overloaded with our
problems
it's also the best of times there's
incredibly good news we have exactly
what we need we have exactly the
platform to save nature
it's called citizen science so citizen
sciences are generally a term used to
mean people without a PhD contributing
to scientific research sometimes it's
called community science which gets at
the communal purpose of citizen science
which is to do something for our Commons
together it's a mature science it's
being turbocharged today by vast
computing power statistical analysis and
a smartphone but it's an ancient
practice that people have always
practiced it's a mature science
professional science has its roots in
amateur science
Charles Darwin was a citizen scientist
he had no advanced degree and he worked
only for himself so someone showed
Darwin this Madagascar star orchid which
has a spur that's 12 inches long and the
spurt is the part of a flower that the
nectar is in so this person showed this
to Darwin and said this proves that
evolution does not come about in an in a
natural way
this flower proves that only God can
make these incredibly bizarre
and tricky looking creatures on the
earth because no insect could possibly
pollinate this God must reproduce it and
Darwin said no I'm sure that there is an
insect somewhere with a proboscis long
enough to pollinate that start working
and he was right this is a map of a
monarch butterfly
so the monarch butterfly is a different
story then that particular moth but
reflects the same kind of fundamental
idea that Darwin had called
coevolution & coevolution is at the
heart of how nature works and it's also
at the heart of what's going wrong with
nature today so over time as the The
Moth developed a longer proboscis so the
plant developed a longer spur over
millions of years the plant and the moth
developed a relationship whereby they
both make each other's chances of
existence better
the monarch butterfly has a different
kind of Co evolutionary relationship and
today it is at the heart of what's going
wrong for the monarch butterfly so this
is a map of the monarch butterfly
migration the monarch does this amazing
thing and over the course of a year it
goes over the entirety of North America
it does this in four or five generations
the first generations only live a couple
of weeks they mate they lay eggs and
they die the next generation emerges as
butterflies and takes the next leg of
the journey nobody knows how they do it
by the time the fifth generation comes
back around and that one lives longer
they overwinter in Mexico and in
California by the time it gets there
those butterflies are going back to
where their ancestors came from but
they've never been there before and
nobody that they're immediately related
to has been there before either we don't
know how they do it the reason we know
they do this kind of migration and they
still have a lot of unanswered questions
about the monarch migration is because
of citizen science so for decades people
have made observations about monarch
butterflies where and when they see them
and they've contributed these
observations to platforms like journey
north this is a map of some observations
of butterflies made by dirt and given to
journey north and if you can see the
dots are coded by what time of year
those observations were made so these
massive amounts of data come into a
place like journey north and they can
create a map of this time of over a
course of a year of where monarchs go
also because of citizen science we
understand that bonhart butterfly
numbers are going down down down
so in the 1980s the overwintering
butterflies here in California there
were four million counted last year
thirty thousand four million to thirty
thousand since the 1980s the monarchs on
the East Coast are doing a little bit
better but they're also going down okay
so what are we going to do about it well
very organically
nobody really asking anybody to do that
people all over the continent are
supporting monarch butterflies the heart
of the problem for monarchs is milkweed
it's another co-evolutionary
relationship and here's the story
milkweed is toxic it has a poison in it
that it evolved to deter other insects
from eating it but the monarch developed
a different kind of relationship a
different strategy with the milkweed not
only does it tolerate the toxin the
monarch actually sequester's the toxin
in its body thus becoming poisonous to
its predators monarch butterflies will
only lay their eggs on milkweed and
monarch caterpillars will only eat
milkweed because they need that toxin to
actually create what they are as a
species
so people are planting milkweed all over
the country where we have lost milkweed
due to habitat destruction pesticide use
herbicide use and climate change impacts
you can create a lot of butterfly
habitat and pollinator habitats on a
windowsill you go to a native nursery in
your area and find out what's native to
where you live and you will bring
beautiful things to yourself now citizen
science can do even more than rescue
monarch butterflies it has the capacity
to scale to the level necessary that we
need to mobilize to save nature and this
is an example it's called city Nature
challenge and City Nature challenge is a
project of the California Academy of
Sciences and the Los Angeles Museum of
Natural History so for four years City
Nature challenge has enjoined cities all
over the globe to participate in
counting up biodiversity in their cities
we're up to like a million observations
of
a biodiversity collected by people
around the globe this past April the
winner this year was South Africa much
to the chagrin of San Francisco they
have more biodiversity than we do so
it's kind of an interesting thing what
is revealed when you start seeing what
are the natural resources where you live
because as we go forward you want to
live where there's more biodiversity and
by the way citizen science is a very
good tool for social justice and
environmental justice goals for helping
reach them you need to have data and you
need to show a picture you need to point
to a cause and then you need to have the
surgical-strike to help support whatever
that problem is so city Nature challenge
I think should get a commendation from
the UN have has there ever been a global
effort on behalf of Nature undertaken in
this coordinated manner it's it's
amazing it's fantastic and it's really a
pretty grassroots thing and we get very
interesting information about
butterflies and other creatures when we
do these bio blitzes City Nature
challenge basically works with a tool
called eye naturalist and eye naturalist
is your entry drug to citizen science I
suggest putting it signing up for it on
a laptop or on the desktop and then you
put the app on your phone with my
naturalist you take a picture of a bird
a bug a snake anything and an artificial
intelligence function and an expert
vetting system works to verify that
observation the app gives the
observation the date the time the
latitude and the longitude geo locates
that observation that's the data that's
the science of citizen science and then
that data is shared and that sharing
that is the soul of citizen science when
we share data we can see much bigger
pictures of what's going on there's no
way to see that whole monarch migration
without sharing data that's been
collected over decades seeing the heart
and soul of how nature works through
citizen science this is a Xerxes blue
butterfly which went extinct when it
lost its habitat in Golden Gate Park it
had a co-evolutionary
with an aunt and that's another story
I'll end by asking you please
participate in citizen science in some
way shape or form it is an amazingly
positive thing it takes an army of
people to make it really work and I'll
just add that I think butterflies
probably really do have enough on their
plate
without carrying around human souls but
there's a lot we don't know right and
what about all those stories what are
those stories telling us maybe we
co-evolved our souls with butterflies
certainly we are connected to
butterflies in deeper ways than we
currently know and the mystery of the
butterfly will never be revealed if we
don't save them so please join me in
helping to save nature now thank you